[Music]
we're very much a company that doesn't
really think about big changes we just
do stuff and hopefully that turns into
big changes and big things for us but
we're always focused on now I'm not a
big idea I don't like the idea of
planning I don't really believe in it I
think it's kind of a waste of time most
the time because you're just guessing
I'd rather just do stuff and so
everything we've done with the company
has been something we wanted to do so we
started out as a web design company
because that's what we wanted to do then
we needed to build software for
ourselves we wanted to do that so we did
that and then we wanted to turn it into
a product and so we did that and then we
wanted to launch another product because
we needed something else so we built
Basecamp when we needed a simple to-do
list maker so we built that called to-do
list and then after that we needed
something else and so we built that so
we're very much a company that's all
about seeing opportunities now and doing
what makes sense for us now and not
thinking about if we make this shift
we're going to be huge or this is going
to be the one thing we need to do once
we've got this done we're going to be
big I'm just a big believer in taking
very small steps along the way and doing
things that just make sense
we started the company in 99 and there
was originally three founders myself and
two other guys kind of going way back I
used to be a web designer I was doing
web design on my son
I'm on the side for myself basically as
a freelancer essentially and I was kind
of sick of doing it by myself so I
started interviewing with some of the
web design firms in Chicago bigger web
design firms in Chicago and one of them
was organic company called organic
online and I interview with them and the
creative director there was a guy named
Ernest Kim and we kind of hit it off but
I didn't really want to work there so we
kind of kept in touch and then I knew
another guy named Carlos Segura who is a
graphic designer in Chicago in earnest
also knew Carlos Segura and so we kind
of had this connection between the three
of us about a year later
Ernest got sick of working for the big
company and he wanted to leave and start
his own small company and I wanted to
kind of work with someone else and
Carlos wanted to get in the web design
world because he's in the print design
world so he said let's start this thing
together and so that's how we all sort
of came together ninety nine and started
37signals together as a web design firm
we were doing website designed for other
clients and we did that for fur let's
see
until about 2003 or so we start getting
really busy and we needed a better way
to manage our client projects so we
started looking at client or a web
design software and project management
software we couldn't find anything that
we really liked so we decided to build
one of our own products to use
internally we started doing that with
clients they really liked it we said hey
maybe there's a product here because
they could use a - and that became
Basecamp and sort of the rest is history
which we can talk about
the best work you'll ever do in your
life is something you do for yourself
the best thing you ever do is what you
spend your own time on for your own good
for your own needs and that's kind of
how we are so we build products that we
need we're a small company we build
products that we need and we recognize
that there's probably a lot of other
people out there just like us who
probably need something just like what
we need not everybody but maybe there's
a hundred thousand maybe there's a
million maybe there's ten million that's
a pretty good market for us we don't
need this like we don't need to capture
a billion people to be successful so
that's been really helpful for us
because when you build something for
yourself and you use it you are a great
judge of quality at that point and you
really understand it like you really
truly understand it unlike when you
build something for somebody else you
don't quite get it you can learn a lot
about it but you don't really know it as
well as you know something that you need
for yourself so and I think the great
companies of the world are typically run
by people who want to use their own
products I mean it's so super cliche to
talk about Apple but I'll do it anyway
because why not if you listen closely to
what Steve Jobs says when he introduces
products it's always something like this
so go
we hope you love it or like you actually
look oh we love it we hope you like it
too and the idea there is that we're
building it for ourselves because we
love this product and we think because
we love it you're going to love it too
and I think most companies that build
great things are building them to to
impress themselves first I mean you look
at companies like great car companies
like Ferrari or Oddie or Porsche like
you just know they're doing this to
satisfy themselves they want to make
something great for themselves because
that's important to them and they know
that if they make something that's great
for themselves other people are going to
love it unlike you maybe GM where it's
not really built for themselves they're
not really that excited about the Ford
Focus probably or that's Ford but you
know they're sort of mildly excited
about it but they're probably like
pumped about it like Ferraris pumped
about building a car so we like the
Ferrari Audie Apple those kind of
companies and even Amazon's a good
example this Amazon built this thing
called Amazon Web Services which is
something they actually had to build
because they needed themselves first to
expand their own business so I think
companies that make things for
themselves typically make better
[Music]